♪ ♪
>> Greg: LAST NIGHT, AN
ELDERLY, CONFUSED MAN WENT
MISSING IN NEW YORK.
LUCKILY A BAND OF SELF-SATISFIED
ELITISTS FOUND HIM BABBLING ON
THE STREETS, THREW SOME PANTS ON
HIM, AND GAVE HIM THE STAGE.
>> I'M GOING TO SAY ONE THING:
TRUMP.
IT'S NO LONGER DOWN WITH TRUMP.
>> Greg: IT KILLS ME.
TALK ABOUT PERSUASIVE.
I WAS ON THE FENCE ABOUT TRUMP
BUT THEN I DECIDED TO REMOVE THE
SEVEN TO ONE OF THE GREAT
GENERATIONAL LEADERS OF AMERICAN
POP CULTURE AND THE CLENCHED
FISTS, THAT DROVE IT HOME.
LOOKS LIKE HE WAS PRESSING A
2-POUND WEIGHT IN A JENNY CRAIG
COMMERCIAL.
LOOK AT IT AGAIN.
IT'S SO CUTE.
IT'S LIKE HE FOUND OUT THAT THE
RESTAURANT SERVES JELL-O OR THAT
HE WON A $10 SCRATCH         SCR
HE WON A $10 SCRATCH         SCT
HE WON A $10 SCRATCH         SCH
HE WON A $10 SCRATCH         SCO
HE WON A $10 SCRATCH         SCF
HE WON A $10 SCRATCH         SCR
HE WON A $10 SCRATCH         SCH
HE WON A $10 SCRATCH         SCE
SCORED A CAMEO IN JERSEY SHORE.
OR HAD HIS FIRST NUMBER TWO IN A
WEEK.
THANK YOU, FIBER CON.
HE WENT FROM RAGING BULL TO THIS
HE WENT FROM RAGING BULL TO THI
THIS.
>> HISTORY IS BEING MADE!
>> Greg: POOR BOB.
HE IS LIKE A STAR WHOSE
GIRLFRIEND DUMPED HIM FOR A
BIGGER STAR, STAR IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WHILE YOU ARE IN "DIRTY
GRANDPA."
THE RESISTANCE IS REDUCED TO A
BLOTTING TANTRUMS WHO KNEW
DE NIRO'S LASTING ROLE WOULD BE
IRRELEVANT GASBAG.
HE'S DOING THIS AS TRUMP
ORGANIZES A SUMMIT, NOT A WAR, A
SUMMIT.
YOU'VE GOT TO WONDER IF IT WERE
PRESIDENT HILLARY, BOB'S CHOICE,
WOULD YOU ACTUALLY HAVE A
SUMMIT?
OR WOULD YOU HAVE A WAR.
WHAT MATTERS IS THAT AD ELATION
RECEIVED FROM AN EMOTIONAL
DISPLAY BEFORE A PACKED SEA OF
MILLIONAIRE LEMMINGS.
WHO CARES THAT TRUMP MEETS WITH
NORTH KOREA.
IT IS NO "MEET THE PARENTS,"
WRITES?
>> ARE YOU TALKING TO ME?
ARE YOU TALKING TO ME?
>> Greg: SIT DOWN.
NOBODY IS TALKING TO YOU ANYMORE
NOBODY IS TALKING TO YOU ANYMOR
ANYMORE.
PATHETIC OLD MAN.
BEFORE I GET TO YOU, LET'S GO --
I THINK HE WAS IN TORONTO
OPENING A RESTAURANT OR
SOMETHING.
THIS IS WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> I WANT TO MAKE A NOTE OF
APOLOGY FOR THE IDIOTIC BEHAVIOR
OF MY PRESIDENT.
IT'S A DISGRACE, AND I APOLOGIZE
TO JUSTIN TRUDEAU AND THE OTHER
PEOPLE AT THE G7.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
>> Greg: I FEEL BAD FOR HIM
BECAUSE I THINK IS ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE THAT'S NEVER EMOTIONALLY
RECOVERED FROM 2016.
THIS IS A GUY WHO HAS SERIOUS
TRUMP DISORDER.
>> Dana: WHERE HE WAS LAST
NIGHT AND WHERE HE IS TODAY, HE
KNOWS HIS AUDIENCE.
WHAT HE DOESN'T KNOW ARE THE
CAST AND CREW OF HIS OWN SHOW.
HE WAS THERE AS PART OF -- THE
MUSICAL HE CODIRECTED.
HIS NAME IS ON THE MARQUEE.
HE NEVER MENTIONS THE SHOW.
THE TIMES THERE'S SO MUCH
COMPETITION IN THE CAST AND CREW
REALLY DESERVED A LOT BETTER.
I THINK THIS WAS EXTREMELY
SELFISH.
YOU NEED PUBLICITY.
THIS WAS THEIR SHOT TO BE ABLE
TO GET A CHANCE TO TALK ABOUT
THE SHOW WHICH I'VE SEEN AND
LOVED IT.
I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY SELFISH.
HE FORGO THE OPPORTUNITY.
HOW DO YOU SAY THAT?
GO SEE "A BRONX TALE," EVEN IF
ROBERT DE NIRO DOESN'T CARE.
>> Greg: HE CHEATED THE TONY
HONOREES BUT I THINK HE MIGHT'VE
HELPED HIM GET REELECTED.
>> Jesse: HOLLYWOOD IS NOT
DOING THE DEMOCRATS A VERY GOOD
SERVICE.
HE IS LIKE THE NANCY PELOSI OF
HOLLYWOOD.
EVERY TIME HE OPENS HIS MOUTH,
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY GOES LIKE
THIS, KEEP TALKING.
YOU ADD THIS TO SAMANTHA BEE
ACROSS -- THEY ARE NOT HELPING
DEMOCRATS GET ELECTED.
WHEN SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAPPENS, IT FIRES UP THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, TURNS OFF
INDEPENDENCE AND DRAGS THE
DEMOCRATS SO FAR TO THE LEFT
THAT THEY CHEER AND THEY THINK
THIS IS ACCEPTABLE.
I WOULD SAY YOU HAVE A CHOICE.
IF YOU ARE A LEFTY PERSON IN THE
COUNTRY AND A CELEBRITY.
YOU'RE EITHER GOING TO RESIST
TRUMP LIKE THIS GUY OR YOU'RE
GOING TO WORK WITH TRUMP.
WE HAVE SEEN CELEBRITIES WORK
WITH TRUMP AND GET THINGS DONE.
I DON'T SEE WHY THESE PEOPLE
DON'T SHOW UP AT THE
OVAL OFFICE.
TRUMP WILL BRING THEM IN.
THEY WILL GET THINGS DONE AND
EVERYBODY WILL SAY IT'S A
WIN-WIN.
IT'S THE EASIEST THING TO DO
WITH THIS PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE NOT TAKING THAT AVENUE.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU'RE
IN A RELATIONSHIP IN WHICH YOU
ARE DUMPED.
THEY ARE STILL DUMPED.
THEY HAVEN'T MOVED ON.
YOU'VE GOT TO MOVE ON.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN HOLLYWOOD WHO
HAVE MOVED ON.
HE HASN'T.
KIMBERLY, I HAVE A THEORY THAT
DE NIRO AND TRUMP ARE THE SAME
AGE.
THE COMPARISON, DE NIRO'S CAREER
IS ON THE DOWNSIDE.
TRUMP IS THE LEADER OF THE FREE
WORLD.
I THINK IT IS EATING HIM ALIVE.
>> Jesse: DE NIRO IS BROKE, IS
THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING?
>> Greg: WHY IS HE DOING
"DIRTY GRANDPA?"
>> Kimberly: HE HURT A PRETTY
PENNY FOR EVERYONE ELSE INVOLVED
IN THE MOVIE.
HE'S NOT WINNING HEARTS AND
MINDS BEHAVING THAT WAY.
POOR THEATRICS.
IT WAS EGOTISTICAL.
WHY TAKE THE MOMENT WAY OF
TRIUMPH AND ADULATION FOR OTHER
PEOPLE WHO WORKED VERY HARD, AND
MAKE IT ABOUT YOURSELF?
VERY MYOPIC IN TERMS OF HIS
VIEWPOINT.
IT'S A CHEAP THRILL HE'S GETTING
FROM SELF.
IT SORT OF SUGGESTS
PSYCHOLOGICALLY HE'S NOT FEELING
SO GREAT ABOUT WHERE HE IS OR
WHAT IS DOING IN LIFE THAN HE IS
TO GO, WE DON'T NEED THEM TO
APOLOGIZE ON BEHALF OF TRUDEAU.
IT IS SO BIZARRE.
NO ONE CAST YOU IN THAT ROLE.
OVER THE NEXT WORLD HE SHOULD
PLACE SOMEONE WHO IS SUPER
JEALOUS AND UNDERACHIEVING AND
ON THE DOWNSIDE.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE HE IS
HOLDING IT TOGETHER WELL.
I REALLY LIKED HIM IN "MEET THE
PARENTS."
THE FOCKERS.
>> Greg: WATCH YOUR MOUTH,
KIMBERLY.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS SWEAR.
YOU DON'T NEED AN INTELLECTUAL
ARGUMENT.
IT WORKS.
>> Juan: WHEN I HEAR YOU TALK
ABOUT ROBERT DE NIRO, MUST BE
ABOUT SOME THE LIST ACTOR.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT ROBERT
DE NIRO, ONE OF THE GREATEST
AMERICAN ACTORS OF ALL TIME.
I DON'T THINK ROBERT DE NIRO IS
IN TROUBLE.
I THINK HE IS STANDING UP THERE,
HE'S A RAGING BULL IN A RAGE
OVER THE OUTRAGEOUS BEHAVIOR OF
THIS PRESIDENT AND IT'S NOT THAT
HE CAN'T GET OVER '16.
IF THAT HE CAN'T GET OVER THE
CURRENT CONTEMPORARY REALITY OF
THINGS LIKE SEPARATING CHILDREN
FROM THEIR PARENTS.
HE CAN'T GET OVER THE IDEA.
THIS PRESIDENT CREATES CHAOS,
ANTAGONIZES OUR ALLIES, EMBRACES
PUTIN, HAS AN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION WHICH HE SAYS HE'S
GOING TO PARDON HIMSELF.
PEOPLE ARE LIKE, WHAT THE --
WHEN YOU SEE ROBERT DE NIRO, A
TRULY DISTINGUISHED ACTOR, MAY
BE THE REASON WHY PEOPLE STAND
UP AND APPLAUD IS BECAUSE THEY
AGREE.
>> Greg: OR THEY HAVE TO.
THEY ARE ON CAMERA.
IMAGINE IF YOU ARE SITTING DOWN
HOW MUCH GRIEF YOU WOULD'VE
GOTTEN.
>> Kimberly: IT IS LIKE THE
CLAP TRACK.
>> Juan: IN THE CONSERVATIVE
ECHO CHAMBER, NOW THEY ARE --
>> Kimberly: MADE THE DE NIRO